vous passez le secret du ski bon j'ai un
document vous proposer une question au
standard pour vous c'est pourquoi je
regardais la du côté de la caméra ce qui
se passait derrière question de hauts
standards est-ce que c'est facile
actuelle facile actuellement de tourner
une comédie en france une vraie bonne
comédie à la française comme vous l'avez
fait avec le soc de l'heure c'est
horriblement débit non pas qu'on ne
trouve pas de producteur pour le faire
mon ami alain poiré et la gaumont je me
suis parfaitement dans ce nom se doit et
gc c'est difficile à faire plus avant
est ce que c'est difficile de faire rire
et que j'ai beaucoup plus visible de
faire rire que quoi que ce soit
alors on ne récolte pas toujours les
fruits il a fallu longtemps pour que la
grande vadrouille ou le corniaud ses
films la trouve un peu leurs lettres de
noblesse mais il faut travailler pour le
public c'est pour le public c'est le
public c'est c'est tout c'est là c'est
la mère qui port où on rame on rame dans
une barque sans hausser fini autrement
si le public n'est pas un défi que vous
avez fait comme la grande vadrouille qui
sont aujourd'hui devenus des films de
légende de la comédie à la française non
c'est vrai des films qui coupe presque
culte ne l'ont pas toujours été non
et lorsqu'ils sont sortis il a fallu
attendre plusieurs années avant qu'il
soit reconnu vraiment que nous gros
succès je crois qu'il faut pas trop
s'occuper de cela et se dire que si le
public est là c'est la joie
alors gouverneur et les récompenses ont
parlé de de funès tout à l'heure
difficile de vous avoir sur le plateau
sans le retrouver d'autant plus que nous
nous avons retrouvé encore un document
baptisé mens beaucoup chercher pour vous
faire plaisir en 1964 une équipe de
télévision se trouvait sur le tournage
du corniaud
il ya un petit mystère donc cette
interview dans ce tournage sur ce
reportage
j'espère que vous allez pouvoir nous
éclairer tout à l'heure en rapport avec
quelqu'un qui vous est cher et qui vous
est proche en rapport avec la
distribution du cordiaux alors on
retrouve à ce reportage de la télévision
française de l'époque
en fait c'est un film comique
un final en collaboration avec groupe et
la présence d'un autre acteur comique
dans un même film de benjamin à
l'encontre est fait pour terriblement le
film et puis une somme de nature
tellement différente on se complète très
bien
j'adore rire et j'adore surtout avoir
des grands partenaires comme dans la
cuisine au beurre
daerden et dans celui ci avec louis de
funès à la yaris est une vraie joie
ce qui n'empêche pas parce que
c'est d'abord c'est un très bon camarade
c'est un personnage qui est charmant
dans la vie et puis c'est un acteur de
grand talent et l'avoir en face de ce
soir je me présente le chesnay mais bon
vous avez pensé à ce que vous allez
faire bonne figure mais oui moi j'ai
quelques montres guess quoique inscrit
j'ai dit j'ai quelques montré un visage
vous avez vu que je fais la france
l'irrésistible regarder sous sûr que
vous savez pas c'est un gars et enfin
développer j'ai dérapé de calais le mac
c'est drôle j'ai encore d'autres trucs
j'ai ça va comme ça vous savez ce geste
à ce que je veux dire regardez ça les
bassins vers de terre qui prend son
virage ça prend l'air de vous emballer
je disais que je n'avais pas tellement
l'air de vous en parler
voilà quel était le numéro d'acteur pour
la télé ça